à
ce qui m'a touché d'abord la première
fois que je les ai vus c'est ça a été
une grande surprise
je suis venu là tu es presque étouffée
par la végétation et on a vu la vraie
véritablement un petit bijou de quelque
chose qui lui dont on sentait bien qu'il
était un moment de rupture il pouvait
peut-être être sauvé il pouvait aussi
complètement disparaître
et justement parce qu'elle était
extrêmement fragiles et extrêmement de
bell
elle nous a donné l'amour de la sauver
c'était il ya dix ans
mal entretenu depuis des décennies la
villa était alors dans un piteux état
mais des éléments témoigner d'une
histoire étonnante que philippe baumel
élu local a voulu faire renaître celle
de céramistes de la fin du 19e qui
décide de construire cette maison à côté
de leur usine avec un sens génial du
marketing il avait l'ambition de faire
la production d'excellence et de luxe
est il pour cela il avait une stratégie
bien à eux qui était de faire travailler
des grands sculpteurs parisienne
notamment ruffier par exemple qui était
à l'époque très très à la mode très très
connu qui venaient ici faire des moules
de pièces d'exception sauf que ces
pièces il fallait démontrer pour que les
clients soient convaincus qu'il fallait
les acheter et donc cette maison a été
un des grands supports qu'ils ont
utilisés pour montrer tout leur talent
tout leur savoir faire
c'est un vrai show room ont passé
visiter l'usiné quand on était client
qui en avant de venir à déjeuner on
faisait le tour de la maison et
l'industriel montré ce qu'ils savaient
faire de mieux et ensuite évidemment ont
partagé un repas et un général ont parlé
à faire vous êtes à la place l'a
probablement des clients parce qu'ils
étaient en les mettez en face le
bâtiment pour qu'ils passent leur temps
à regarder
justement les productions personnes et
pour aller au bout de leur logique les
perrusson construisent la villa à côté
de la voie ferrée afin de montrer aux
passagers du train le savoir faire de
l'entreprise en matière de formes et de
couleurs
il ya énormément de couleurs différentes
il ya des couleurs exceptionnelles on
parle parfois de neuf jaunes perrusson
genillé très fier on ne sait pas si
c'est un grand courant de peinture
intéressant voilà on l'envoie un
échantillon ici lors celui là et adra
l'origine n'a pas été refait mais vous
un peu plus au dessus de la fenêtre ici
vous voyez des éléments couleur jaune ce
jaune très criants quelqu'un très chaud
qui justement appelée l'oeil aussi
beaucoup et qui étaient à la mode à
l'époque et bien voilà c'est ça le jeu
intéressant
pendant des décennies les céramiques
perrusson sont à la mode
puis vient le temps des formes plus
épurée mais les perrusson restent
fidèles à leurs traditions et lusine
périclite
la villa est vendu et négliger lorsque
la communauté de communes la rachète
pour lui rendre son lustre
la tâche est immense et ardue pour les
artisans sollicité car tout est à
refaire et à réinventer beaucoup de
techniques ont été oubliés on s'est
retrouvé dans la situation immense
d'être obligés d'adapter à chaque pièce
notre savoir et à le renouveler et a
frôlé l'échec à chaque fois une des
difficultés de ce chantier c'est
finalement le nombre de pièces par
exemple offert cette fleur il a fallu
faire 4 4 pièces 4 morizet au total 400
pièces de 50 formes différentes ont dû
être refaite une complexité accentuée
par le fait que la terre se rétracte
lors du séchage parfois de plus de dix
centimètres
la dessiccation l'évaporation ce fait
extrêmement vite et ça pose problème
donc il faut couvrir les pièces voilà je
les mesures aient tous les jours je les
mesures et pour savoir si à mon avis
elle était dans la bonne logique
autre grand chantier celui du lanternon
créées pour l'exposition universelle de
paris de 1889 installé au pied de la
tour eiffel
il est démontée puis ré installé dans la
maison vitrine où le temps et les
intempéries lui seront fatales c'est
vrai que ces ouvrages le plus
intéressant à restaurer dans la maison
et il a demandé un peu d'études pour en
cours de restauration arriver à faire un
ouvrage qui soient pérennes et qui
résiste au temps parce que un ouvrage en
terre cuite posés sur des colonnettes en
terre cuite
ça n'existe pas de façon structurée
lifou l'atp ne peut pas porter les
charges les colonnettes ont donc été
consolidée ainsi que la base puis la
coupole dessus grâce à de nombreuses
astuces un travail complété par celui du
jardin aménagé de façon à offrir de
belles perspectives sur la villa il sera
régulièrement le lieu d'animations et
d'expositions
en attendant un autre chantier la
restauration de l'intérieur de la maison